the girag an experience right and yin
you can't trust if you're a team in 80
year old billionaire you can't trust a
girl who's willing to fuck you with
tapes exactly so that is like a lot of
like it's like three people fucking up
you know what I thought was the most
bizarre about all of it apparently I was
correct and that what she as far as the
most recent story is that she was
supposed to record his saying his
conversations because he would say
things and then forgot he said him right
so he's got he's dementia right 81 years
old he's old as fuck so he would say
crazy things and then she would record
them and you know and let him know like
what he said right well in this case
somehow another it got leaked how it got
leaked to speculation but he knew he was
being recorded right that is true so you
can't it's against a lot of record
anyone like what if they don't say
anything is just bathroom noises and
stuff yes law still even if they don't
talk in absolutely in California they
don't know about it it's against the law
you're not allowed to record your
essence can be like if you just put a
tape recorder down behind the toilet
they don't say a word they just that you
know that and then they leave that's
still against a lot even though they
don't say it it's there just their
spirit being in the room the noises of
them being recorded there are actual
physical presence being marked by the
sound of their feet I think that's
probably illegal really that's what is
it a criminal do you say so myself
guilty as fuck why Josh it's a really
weird question he's like this so smooth
if you take a tape and put it behind you
say inver pointless imperfect whatever
whatever and the girl might happen to be
a stripper whenever whatever mean that's
that combination it's never gonna happen
but if it did it's just I'd know that
you were recording her pooping just
interesting because I guess so
accordingly no no Brian that's not
interesting fucking space is interesting
we talked about that you play them up
any like oh you can't require people
poopin all the real issue with putting
all of your eggs in one basket in life
and that basket being athletics and
especially athletic especially combat
athletic yeah
the idea that you're going to have some
sort of a long and successful fruitful
career by throwing your bones and
another person trying to separate
themselves from their consciousness
that's quite ridiculous yeah because
just the very act of doing it in
preparing for that very act if to the
amount of damage that your body and your
brain even indoors this but we have this
idea in our heads that you know a guy
has to be an undefeated champion yeah
you know you my son is going to be a
champion someday like man if you're
really lucky your son won't be a
champion yeah really lucky your son will
learn the valuable lessons of martial
arts as far as like character
development and as far as your ability
to overcome what seemed to be
unsurmountable obstacles but to become a
champion you have to be a crazy person
yeah if the crazy person who's obsessed
with nothing but that and that will take
over your life yeah and I feel like
having worked obviously with people like
that you know shadowed them and and
recognizing that mindset um uh I you
know and I find to like there's just
some point at which like there's some
gifts that are just bestowed by genetics
or something and done matter how hard
you work you're not going to quite get
to them maybe that level that separates
the real and you won't know that until
you hit it you know what I mean you're
not going to know that wall until you
run into it and I feel like for some
people like I was talking to one guy
just a guy at the gym and and he said
something more or less like the best
that he he ever felt in a fight was when
he was up against someone he knew was
better than him and he knew he was gonna
lose and if they fought a hundred times
he'd lose a hundred times but he that
guy he made that guy see something about
himself he got that close to him it that
the other guy sort of recognized I'm a
frail I made out of the same crumbling
stuff that he's made out of and so you
know sort of pierce that Teflon armor
that that I think some fighters carry
around with themselves he's like that's
that's all I could do that for me is the
victory I still lost but I made that guy
discover something about himself that he
hadn't discovered up until that point
because he'd never been tested to the
point that I got to I wasn't able to
test him I thought that's another part
about just being recognizing
you're able to do you know and it may
not be beating them but it's you you
find some other measure of success you
eat first of all you being a veteran and
you you being unabashed in your love for
soldiers and your respect for your
fellow military members when you got on
top of that cage and after you know they
were cheering and you were yelling out
to all those people that you love them I
mean this is all off camera man we'd cut
to commercial and you're on top of the
cage and you're just yelling and all
those people let him know that you love
them that's some intense intense shit
yeah overwhelming emotional near shut
down yeah I'm walking out to the cage I
see this dude he flies for the 160th
which is like the Special Forces wing of
aviation the last time I saw that dude
was I was handing him my shot buddy you
know I'm like it's a big thing in
Special Forces community were real tight
you know like I'm handing him my brother
that has bullet holes in him and and I'm
like I don't let him go and he's like
hey I got this this is what I do you go
do what you're supposed to do and get
back to work that's the last time I saw
this dude was handing him my buddy on a
medevac then I'm walking out of the cage
I was like holy shit there is that dude
from the 160th that I handed my shot
buddy to totally overwhelming that after
go in there and fight and then uh you
know nice 5th Special Forces Group is
co-located there so I saw a bunch of
dudes from like the Green Beret regiment
yeah it's entirely too much motion I
just wanted to like curl up and cry yeah
it's a completely different kind of it
there's you on top of the cage up there
in that photo that's just an intense
intense picture that picture should be
framed and on your wall somewhere
because that is one of the greatest
pictures that I've ever seen if you
could cut me out and just have the dudes
no no no no no you need to be in there
for reference yeah I mean but that's
your attitude what you just said cut me
out and leave the dudes that that really
is your attitude you you really don't
want that you were saying while you were
up there that my job is is in here is
easy what you guys do you guys are my
heroes yeah you know good memory yeah I
remember everything it's disturbing haha
scary don't get if I Joe Rogan
really